for an extra special way to celebrate
the holidays and entertain the entire
family at the same time you need to
visit the Las Vegas Natural History
Museum's a December to remember exhibit
now here tell us more is executive
director Kate Porter welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me it's
great to see you again December to
remember tell us more about this so this
is a long-standing celebration of
traditions from all over the world
created by community members right here
in Las Vegas what are some of the
Traditions that we're going to see
celebrated well one of the oddest
Traditions you'll see is Mari Lloyd this
is from the south of Wales and
traditionally folks would take the horse
goals decorate them and then they go
from house to house for good luck but
we've got all sorts of other Traditions
represented from the Philippines from
Scotland the wiccans the Nevada Buddhist
Association You Name It Las Vegas is
there this is so interesting and so
unique and this is something for the
entire family correct totally and there
are workshops as well and they're
specifically geared to be four families
so folks of all ages can come and
experience the cultures from the people
themselves and this time of year too you
have family coming to town you have the
kids are out of school you're looking
for something to do this is a great
experience there are there you're saying
there's live demonstrations happening
when does this take place correct so
most of them are on the weekends however
we do actually have a dreidel Workshop
coming up from the Nevada Jewish
Federation on the 21st that is that is
so cool you guys have so many things
happening there what are some of the
exhibits or some of the other things we
should see in the museum right now oh
man we bring the wonders of the world to
life at our Museum truly so in addition
to all of these different cultures
they're so beautifully represented we
also offer dinosaurs ancient Egypt
Africa wild Nevada geology you name it
if it's natural history we've got it it
is a full day experience we were there
over the summer doing some stuff with
Jurassic Park coming out and looking at
the dinosaurs and we wrapped up at like
three o'clock we wanted to stay there
all afternoon because there was so much
to see inside the museum truly truly
we've got forty thousand square feet a
working paleontology lab and fun for
everyone and it's educational too it
certainly is and you can entertain the
family okay thank you so much for
joining us we appreciate it thank you
happy holidays same to you